all right so what's the second thing I
did oh oh oh what I'm sure you want now
I have so many things that you have
found okay good good what you will go
tit for tat good
oh you waited for that idea all right
this guy calls me right and he goes get
it over because I was on a sitcom called
animal practice uh-huh he got canceled
and I was really hurt by it sure it was
a really tough time because I didn't
have kalila at the time and that was I
called you the night it premiered I bet
you don't remember that I know thank you
I watched it I said congratulate you he
doesn't make you forgets these things
counts right I watched it so then he
calls me go sorry about animal practice
but you don't have a show maybe yeah
Sullivan & Son right because yeah I was
thinking about you know um me know
writing a character with you in it like
so reoccurring and it's gonna be really
cool and you know at the time a med was
on it the wonderful and the
multi-faceted Owen Benjamin you know
mean just the pure talent that he is of
course and I go yeah you gonna write you
know you know when somebody calls you
for something like that you start you
lay down in bed and you start
fantasizing what it's gonna be like at
the Warner Brothers lot you know what
it's like rehearsing laughing with your
friends you're actually working you're
on TV with your you know it there's
nothing better right and then three
months later I find out ken Jeong is
doing it did that that did not did that
happen your your old pal Ryan Jahnke so
my thing is is this okay I know why that
happened yeah you think you know why it
happened and you bring this up
I let you're wrong you're tired right
now your eyes you're getting wrathful my
eyes are a full-ride tired
let me just rage fully tired
gratefully tired I know okay so it
doesn't make any sense okay but we're in
a different planet right now okay and
all we are yeah and we're not gonna get
to a point you and I we're gonna scream
each other because I love you and I love
what right now you I love what we're
doing right now it's fun and we're
mending things and that's great okay
okay so on the reason why I think the
reason why and I think this is the
reason why is because you're the guy
that was producing it doesn't like me
that is not true
he likes me let me ask you something yes
does Vince Vaughn like me yes I'm
looking you in the eyes oh yeah Wow
yeah I think in my head I corrected they
correct me if I'm wrong here we go I
don't know his story so I don't know
Bobby has an ability to go down the
rabbit hole I think sometimes of
insecurity and make things a bigger deal
than they actually are correct thank you
so I think that there are times where
you get things in your head and you
start making them via osmosis insecurity
which you're you know you told me at
times that you you know I think we all
do anybody in this business does right
but I think I'm glad you said that I
don't know if these two words should
ever make sense together otherwise but I
think it makes sense for Bobby where
there is an insecure narcissism by that
I mean I was going to say Rachel II
tired but you know like it doesn't make
sense together but I think with you at
us where you take a situation like that
yeah and you morph it into your head
there's a self-importance there and
thinking someone hates you that much yes
actually slapped and pondered about
their hatred for you when in reality
they probably don't at all at all and
you make alright fine okay I'm gonna say
this I'll say okay I'll say this because
I let me say alright let me ask you give
me a little titty I'm gonna give a
little teddy I'm gonna give you that I'm
gonna give you
Partin teddy right now okay okay so are
you seeing a brother say what yeah are
you saying to me then yeah that he's
never had hard feelings toward me I can
honestly tell you that is correct he's
never had hard feelings towards you Wow
Wow
so when we used to because I used to
hang out with the guy right right and
then all of a sudden he if I say hi
don't meet wasn't saying hi back what is
that okay see here's what I know
okay you're asking me what I know from
my own personal riots and from your own
personal experience from the time I've
met him which has been many years yeah
some time I've known you which has been
many yeah yeah foreign time in Hollywood
you spend many years yeah I've never
seen him exhibit anything towards you or
personally to me that has been of
negative nature oh I see yeah but I just
can't do stuff that he's producing that
movie that you did you know me at the
comedy with you Jimmy O yang with that
movie right you said I could be in it
right and I wasn't in it why when I
wrote this okay look at his eyes
basically tied up because his eyes turn
white your eyes turn white the wider
when you lie my eyes turn we're half
white lie yes so it punches in it's cool
go ahead this payment value of this show
has gotten flatter so tell me flatter so
tell me so when this all starts coming
to fruition right I did have a
discussion with you right about hey you
know I had this thing going on there's
gonna be some roles that are gonna be in
developing and I'd love to talk to you
down the line and include you I did say
that yeah right okay so the minute this
thing goes to to the hill right and it's
like okay we're in pre-production we got
to get going all the sudden things start
spiraling it's done by committee and
it's not just me so if I was just solely
in charge of doing things right I think
the casting would have been different on
many different fronts for example Billy
Gardell
you know Billy loved them Mike and Molly
right yeah okay so I had a conversation
with Billy about about potentially
playing the headliner in this film
uh-huh and when this is all going okay
there's producers there's investors and
the investors have their input to put as
well I'm trying to be diplomatic because
I'm still obviously in the throes of of
completing this so there is a process of
which we've got to decide these things
by committee and if I look one of the
most difficult conversations I've ever
had in my life was to call Billy Gardell
and say hey I'm sorry but it's just not
gonna work out and I had I named the
character Billy G he's named who took al
who took the part Cedric the Entertainer
but it's not who took it
it's also when you're casting I know
what works man
so I know how it [ __ ] works I know
because you're always by your typewriter
creating so I know but I have been on
you know shows right and I in the end
they go who's great for this part and we
throw our names right that we like right
and there's a gigantic process where
everyone has their say-so I understand
how it there are in that exact right
there are people that say why I think X
Y Z is great I think ABCs great right
then it's also representatives getting
involved yeah no that's not for saying
though it wasn't even for a specific
part you were calling me about this come
for a day and we'll fit you in and
improvise even that was on the you know
it wasn't as if you know I was gonna do
a lead role in the first minute I get we
were saying and I want to believe you
and I'm what I do want to believe you
know and I'm probably 70% there okay
right
that means everything to me okay so I've
been waiting
yeah I'm 70% there I'll never know the
truth Yeah right and I'll never know and
I may never know that 30% and that's
what's gonna [ __ ] me that's that's
what I take to the grass room what was
it like to get that 30% cuz then Bobby
would answer my text messages
Oh